الحب هو المغفره التي لا نهايه لها نهايه
والعطاء الذي يصبح عاده اما علميا فهناك
ما يعرف بهرمون الحب اقصيتوسين المسؤول عن
الترابط الاجتماعي بين البشر
وتغطيه العلاقات بين الازواج والابناء
والاسر دراسه جديده اجريت في جامعه
كاليفورنيا قررت تحدي تلك الثوابت
والدراسات التي اجركت على مدى عقود بعدما
كشفت نتائجها ان الفئران براري معدله
جينيه استطاعت تكوين علاقات طويله الامد
مع شريك واحد حتى بعد نزع مستقبلات
اكسيتوسين تمكنت من الاعتناء بالصغارها
بشكل طبيعي لكن لاحظ العلماء ان
المستقبلات لا تلعب دورا مهما في نمو
الصغار حيث واجهت صعوبه في البقاء على قيد
الحياه حتى السنه
او هرمون الحب قد يكون احد اطرافه معادله
الحب والترابط لانساني وطرف خيط من
العمليات الكيميائيه
التي تساعد في تقويم العلاقات الاجتماعيه
سوهاج جميل من الاردن
[موسيقى]
قلب يدق مشاعر صاخبه تتدفق وحيات اخرى
يعيشها الذين يقعون في الحب غارقين في
لذته التي لا تنتهي
بامله
يبقى الحب احد اجمل الاشياء في حياتنا لكن
مهلا ما هو الحب وكيف ياتي وما هي
العلاقات التي تنطوي تحت هذا الاحساس الذي
نعتبره حبا حقيقيا
[موسيقى]
السر الكبير في الاكسيتوسين او ما يعرفوا
بهرمون الحب فهو صاحب الكلمه العليا بين
ثنائيات العاطفيه سواء كان بين المحبين
التقليديين من العشاق او بين الام
وابنائها
فهو المحرك الفعال في تاجج المشاعر
والمانح السحري لاكسير العشق الازلي لمن
جمعتهم الاقدار ليكون عشاقا
هذا ما كنا نعرفه عن هذا الهرمون من خلال
دراسات سابقه لكن دراسه جديده اجريت حديثا
على فئران البراري المعروفه بعلاقاتها
الاجتماعيه والعاطفيه والتي تشبه الى حد
كبير حياتنا الاجتماعيه كبشر تنفي الامر
في جملته وتقول انه رغم ازاله مستقبلات
الحب من هذه الفئران الا انها بقيت قادره
على بناء علاقات قويه كثينائيات وبقيه
الامهات تعتني بصغارها
الدراسه التي اجريت في جامعه كاليفورنيا
تفتح الباب على مسرعيه امام البحث في
العوامل الوراثيه التي تتحكم في السلوك
الاجتماعي والعاطفي كاشفه ان الاكسيتوسين
ليس سوى واحد من عده عوامل تنظم هذه
السلوكيات المعقده يبقى الحب سرا كبيرا في
قلوبنا وعقولنا سر قادر على ان يغير
حياتنا للافضل ان كان في محله وللاسوا ان
جاء في غيره مكانه
[موسيقى]
اذا ما هو هرمون الحب
الاوكسيتوسين هو ناقل عصبي للدماغ له دور
مهم في العديد من السلوكيات البشريه
والتفاعلات الاجتماعيه بما في ذلك الثقه
والاثاره الجنسيه والارتباط العاطفي وايضا
الترابط بين الوالدين والرضيع افرازه هذا
الهرمون يرتبط على الاغلب بوجود شخص اخر
اي شكل من اشكال الترابط الاجتماعي او
الاتصال الجسدي الايجابي يمكن ان يحفزه
هرمون الحب حتى خلال مشاركه الوجبات مع
اشخاص نحبهم بطبيعه الحال تملكه
بالرجال حيث يساعد الهرمون على تحفيز
الرحم اثناء المخاض والولاده وتحفيز انسجه
الثدي للمساعده على الرضاعه بعد الولاده
رغم ذلك الاكسيتوسين لا علاقه له مباشره
بمشاعر الاسترخاء او الاستقرار النفسي بل
يمكن ان يكون مسؤلا ايضا عن مشاعر سلبيه
مثل الغيره والحسد والشماته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بالنسبه لي يكون اهتمام تمام بين الاثنين
ولو مش شرط مش ما يكونوش مخطوبين او
متجوزين بس اهم حاجه بين الناس لازم الحب
بينهم والاهتمام الكويس يعني عامه
تسلم حياتي اهم حاجه
واولادي طبعا انا بحب ولادي بس ربنا
يهديهم الحب ثقه امان
تفاصيل كثيره يعني مش حاجه واحده بالنسبه
لي الحب كل الناس تسامح بعضه تحب بعض تحب
بعض يعني ايه في المعامله ان احنا نعمل
بعض كويس الحب اللي لابسها جميله قوي
سواء اذا كان بين زوجين بين الاصدقاء
بين اقارب بين جيران بس اهم حاجه فيها
لمسه الحب الحقيقيه ابنها تكون النيه
حب اي عمل معمول بحب او باتقان هيطلع حلو
اي حد بنعامله في المعامله دي حب هيبقى في
معامله حسنه ومعامله جيده من غير حب
الحياه ما تسواش او ما نقدرش نعيشها
[موسيقى]
على كلن ينضم الى الدكتور نادي رياضي
دكتور نادر يسعد صباحك اهلا بك من الناحيه
نفسيه هل بالفعل يمكننا العيش بحب حتى من
دون علميا هرمون الحب او مستقبلات الحب
اللي هي الاكسيتوسين
الموضوع فكره هرمون الحب عشان بس الناس
موضوع الحب هذا الموضوع فلسفه يمكن حد
يتناقش فيه 17 20 حلقه كل سنه حيتكرر
موضوع انه الهرمون بياثر على علاقه الحب
او لا يؤثر مش هو هذا المصدر الرئيسي
بالذات
البحث اللي كان بيحكي على الفئران
والاشياء هذه والام وازاي كيفيه التكوين
هذا الاشياء شوفي انا هاقول لك حاجه مهمه
جدا في علاقتنا في قصصنا في الحب
عليها كنت اول مره اسلم عليك مش دائما كل
مره
هذه المشاعر حضرتك انا سلمت عليك بايدك
او لحبيبك
في ايده هتلاقي في مشاعر مختلفه ولما انت
بتكوني بقى لك فتره مش شايفاه وتمسك يده
هتلاقي فيها حنان حضرتك اللي خلقتي هذا
الشيء ما في له علاقه بالهرمونات اللي لها
علاقه بالسعاده ولا بالحب ولا شيء يتم
تخزين هذه الاشياء خليني اقولها لك ببساطه
اي شخص بيكون في حياتنا شخص شخص طبيعي
ممكن نشوفه الي جوزناه او حبنا ليش نحن
بنخلق انه حضنه هيكون غير لمسه ايده هتكون
غالي مين اللي خلقها هذا مش الحرمه نقعد
العقل الله عنا مع العلم ممكن يكون واحد
زميلك في الشغل او انت بتعرفيه ابن عمك
اللي اتجوزتيه اللي قبل شهرين ثلاثه اربعه
كان عادي لمسه يده ان احنا اللي بنخلق هذه
الهاله والرومانسيه الكبيره واللي بنعاني
معهم ناس كثير جدا انه مش قادر تنسى
حبيبها
اللي بدك اياه الان في موضوع الحب
طب خلينا هلا نروح هيك شوي لمن حدا ثاني
لانه هل الهرمون الحب
مفعل ويعمل فقط بين الجنسين بين امراه
ورجل ولا كمان هرمون الحب موجود بين الام
لاولادها همم امراه لصديقتها مثلا
انا عشان يكون هرمون الحب يشتغل لازم يكون
في محفز مش هينفع انا اكون دائما ماشي في
الشارع كل ما اشوف واحده هرمون الحب اشتغل
معايا ولا انت هتكون ماشيه في قاعده في
مكان وقاعده كل شويه هتشوف وحده من زمان
الحب بيشتغل هرمون الحب هيشتغل لما يكون
فيه بدون هذا المحافظ يشتغل هذا هرمون
الحب يعني انا ممكن يشتغل معي
ذكر مع ذكر والعكس صحيح ممكن يشتغل معي مع
اي شيء
انت انت اللي خليتي لمسه يدك للشخص اللي
بتحبيه اهم لمسه يد العاديه اللي انا
لمستيها فيها لمسه عابره طيب ما هو كان
ممكن نفس الشخص هذا اللي انت بتحبيه انت
عايشه معه اليوم ممكن يكون في الاخر وكمان
لمسه عابره انت اللي خلقتي هذا الشيء
بعدين بيجي هرمون الحب لكن مش هرمون الحب
اللي فرض عليك لا انت لسه لو لمست اليد
الدكتور نادر هيكون عاديه يعني
احنا اللي بنعمل هذا الشيء هاقول لك حاجه
اكبر من هيك طب ما احنا بنكون بنحب واحد
كثير جدا
هو حرمان الحب اختفى اخذه اذن وراح روح
لحاله لا فجاه تتحول هذه كليتها اشياء حقد
ولونها اسود اذا هو هرمون الحب يشتغل او
تشتغل بناء على التحفيز الصور اللي احنا
بنعطيه يعني
الحب لحظه تايدها
لحظات هي فقط هي البدايه هي بدايه الحب
لحظات
حاله حب يعني في مثلا ممكن بهذا الاسبوع
بتيجي لحظات حب بهذا اليوم لحظات بس مش
حاله عامه
رومانسيه اكثر كل ما اوه انا مش قادر
اتسكر يده
الاشياء هذه
الاشياء انت واقعيه جدا
[موسيقى]
من الحب
[ضحك]
ان شاء الله